but the oscar-nominated for Pride and
Prejudice congratulations and this is an
odd thing to talk to someone about but
that he banned poaching yeah nope so do
you know you packed well yeah it was not
I didn't see I didn't see i think now
i've got out now no part about as far as
i'm concerned okay yeah yeah no I had a
little moment I never liked my I didn't
like my smile lots of people had said I
had a cracked smile so anytime I had a
picture taken like I'd always broke you
know like that and then suddenly there'd
be a film camera and I thought Annie Joe
is like now you know you've got it
you've got to stop the pout so I wasn't
allowed to Pat then we started doing
Chanel adverts and then all of a sudden
he's like you know that palette that I
ban can we just have it back as much as
possible trying to get it out there is
actually one shot in the film that was
done by the second unit director in
Pride and Prejudice where the power is
there and every time he watched it he's
still like you got one because it's a
very female thing men doing men can pass
it just look like you're about to
appetite Churchill's car insurance
oh yeah but I think you are
disadvantaged a man with no lips
Department it's a lipless world for me
but it's a happy one
[Applause]
and you gotta think I hate y'all
couldn't and it looked like that I just
couldn't look like that but I was in one
wiki for Sutherland it was funny and he
came out he said me hate man he said I
haven't screamed so much as I was
married